Bruno on va parler du de la suite du
remanillement qui se fait attendre
est-ce que cette décision de justicire
concernant François Baayou he peut
expliquer le temps qui est mis pour la
suite de ce remanement et de est-ce que
c'est quand même un soulagement dans le
camp de la majorité présidentielle oui
on peut pas exclure que ça joue
effectivement un rôle et que du côté de
l'exécutif on doit être un peu en
standby sur la composition compléter la
composition du gouvernement parce que
c'est François Barou c'est un des
piliers à la fois de notre vie politique
mais aussi de la majorité le président
du MoDem représente l'allié principal au
fond d'Emmanuel Macron une cinquantaine
de députés du Modem François beou et
joué un rôle capital dans l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 donc on voit
bien qu'on devit être un peu en standby
de cette décision de de justice François
beayou de son côté a été relaxé relâché
relaxéon simple été relaxé en fait et
c'est vrai que pour lui à titre
personnel c'est un soulagement mais en
toile de fond il y a quand même c'est
compliqué le mouvement politique la
personne morale modemme elle a été
condamnée la décision du Tribunal
reconnaît qu'il a détournement de fond
public au profit du mouvement politique
d'autres cadres du mouvement ont été
condamnés des peines d'emprisonnement
avec sourcil des amants donc on voit
quand même que pour le président du du
modemme c'est un soulagement personnel
mais son mouvement politique l'image de
son mouvement politique alors que un des
piliers de ce mouvement politique c'est
incarné une forme de politique
fait sur la probité une nouvelle manière
de faire de la politique la moralisation
dossier sur lequel François baayrou a
été très longtemps en pointe on se
rappelle de ces passes d'armes avec
Nicolas Sarkozi en particulier sur cette
question le président du Monet av publié
un livre qui qui Pil qui passait au
pilori l'ancien président de la
République sur ces sur ces questions là
donc quand même une situation qui est
qui n'est pas complètement on va dire
complètement réglé pour le pour le modem
en tout cas est-ce que c'est une
décision c'est vrai Bruno le dire en
demi-teinte quand même pour François
berou lui personnellement est soulagé
mais sa ligne politique en prend un coup
oui al je pense pas que les Français
fassent cette distinction c'est vrai que
le niveau d'intérêt pour ce procès était
extrêmement limité on le voyait dans nos
conversations des Français il fo
Fiducial pour Paris Match et SUD RADIO
j'ai pas l'impression que ça a beaucoup
passé le mur du son de l'opinion c'est
vrai que pour vossin baayerou c'est un
soulagement absolument incroyable alors
est-ce que ça explique la lenteur
d'exécution de cette deuxème partie du
remanimement pas sûr puisque on sait que
depuis le début de l'air Emmanuel Macron
le processus de remanimement a toujours
été extrêmement lent 20 jours ou 21
jours pour le remanimement pour Jean
Castex une vingtaine de jours pour
Madame borne là on est à 22 23 jours
alors une fois de plus au risque de
jouer les mauvais coucheurs l'intérêt
des Français pour ce remanement est
extrêmement limité d'une part les
Français sont sur une logique de
résultat pas sur une logique de casting
même s'il peut y avoir un effet de sur
surprise la nomination de rachti et puis
il faut le dire pour une majorité des
Français les faits waou si je puux dire
ou le la nouveuté ce qui a frappé c'est
ce qui s'est passé début janvier la
nomination de ce jeune premier ministre
qui pour l'instant ne connaît pas un
état de grâce mais bénéficie d'un réel
crédit de confiance maintenant je
j'observe avec un peu d'amusement
Françis Baou qui dit je n'écarte rien
quand une quand as une nomination du
gouvernement à ce que che on ne se nomme
pas au gouvernement c'est le premier
ministre c'est le c'est le le président
sur proposition du Premier ministre S
qui nomme les ministres mais ça montre
aussi le statut à part qu'à François
Baayou qui a été le faiseur de roi c'est
lui qui en 2017 en se retirant on se
souvient dans notre ring Fiducial la qui
a laissé la possibilité à Emmanuel
Macron d'entrevoir le second tour
effectivement François baayrou qui
n'écarte pas sa propre entrée au
gouvernement et d'ailleurs il est même
allé plus loin puisqu'il a précisé qu'il
y avait je cite des troubles dans
l'éducation nationale ça vise avec
peut-être peu de finesse la ministre
actuelle de l'éducation nationale et des
Sports améie oua casterra qui est
empêtré dans une spirale négative de
polémique depuis sa nomination au
gouvernement donc il y a cette
perspective ministérielle pour François
Baayou et c'est vrai que pour le modem
la condamnation du mouvement complique
les choses d'autant qu'actuellement et
bien le modem est très peu présent dans
les principaux ministère de Gabriel Atal
seul Marc F a été reconduit à la tête du
ministère de l'Agriculture et après
cette première save de nomination et
bien les cadres du MoDem le disaient le
compte n'y est pas nous sommes un allié
d'Emmanuel Macron dans la majorité
présidentielle et nous ne sommes pas
assez représentés donc voilà ça pourrait
se compliquer encore dans les prochaines
nominations pour le mod ou ils était
quatre au gouvernement pour le moment il
y en a qu'un seul je pense qu'ils savent
qu'ils iront pas à 5 mais évidemment
l'objectif pour eux c'est de retrouver
les quatre mais estce que là ça redonne
du politique cette DC comme on est sur
un gouvernement qui quand même veut
incarner un gouvernement plus restreint
ça va être sans doute compliqué beaucoup
au sein de la majorité vont sans doute
compter retrouver leur postees mais il y
a un gouvernement plus restreint donc ça
va être plus compliqué alors
effectivement la question est de savoir
si la décision de justice d'hier redonne
au modème de la marge de manœuvre pour
négocier effectivement de conserver ses
postes au gouvernement c'est pas c'est
pas certain parce que c'est un jeu de
contrainte quand même qui est très qui
est très important il faut un
gouvernement paritaire il faut un
gouvernement resserré il faut des
équipes is éal voilà absolument il y a
toujours aussi de la composition d'un
gouvernement toujours l'idée un peu
d'une aussi d'une représentativité un
peu territoriale du du pays donc une
équation qui n'est qui n'est pas simple
on verra effectivement donc tout le
monde est dans l'attente de cette
composition du du du du gouvernement et
notamment je pense de de voir si
certains domaines de l'action publique
qui pour le moment n'ont pas de ministre
vont être soit regroupé dans des
poules de portefeuille ministériel ou
s'ils vont trouver des des des des
ministres à part entière avec grande
interrogation sur l'éducation c'est là
où le babless j'ai dit peut-être un peu
rapidement que le niveau d'intérêt des
Français pour maniment était faible je
le dis toujours mais il y a quand même
dans nos enquêtes qualitatives une
interrogation sur le fait que mais al
c'est l'avatard d'un gouvernement
resserré d'un 15 de France d'una on
connait cet imaginaire politique
l'absence pour l'instant depuis
maintenant plus de 3 semaines de
ministres responsable de sujet au cœur
des préoccupations des Français santé
grand âge handicap logement logement F
publi ça transport on est vraiment sur
toute une série de sujets qui sont
vraiment font partie dans du top 10 si
je puis dire des principaux enjeux qui
comptent pour les Français donc ce
remanement va permettre de désigner des
titulaires parce que une politique n est
intimement lié à une incarnation une
politique ça s'incarne maintenant c'est
vrai puis Bruno l'a très bien dit que
quand on a beaucoup communiqué dans la
première partie du remanimement sur le
gouvernement resserré sur le 15 de
France le cap c'est difficile après de
lâcher les chevaux si je puis dire et
d'être sur un gouvernement extrêmement
plétorique et là la le rapport de force
entre le nombre de ministres horizon et
le nombre de ministres modem va être
important pour entrevoir les équilibres
au sein de la majorité présidentielle et
et la ligne peut-être parce que
effectivement il y a les questions de
personne combien de modem mais il y a
aussi François beirou qui appelle à
recentrer à rééquilibrer le gouvernement
qui juge trop pas droite est-ce que du
coup ça va pousser Emmanuel Macron à
réorienter la ligne de son gouvernement
le cette relaxe de François qui reprend
du poids politique problème compliqué
parce que effectivement il y a en toile
de fond cette question de la ligne
François
baayerou depuis de nombreuses semaines
dit que il faut corriger la trajectoire
qu'il faut revenir au macronisme de
départ il faut rester fidèle à son et de
gauche et de droite à cette vision
centriste de François Baayou qui trouve
que ça glisse trop à droite bien
évidemment donc il y a évidemment ça qui
est en en ligne de mire mais il y a le
problème toujours de l'absence de Major
é à l'Assemblée nationale et pas
seulement d'ailleurs la question de
l'absence de de majorité on a un
discours du premier ministre qui est un
discours sur lequel je pense que
beaucoup d'électricesélecteurs ont
retenu surtout la question de de
l'autorité la restauration de l'autorité
une action publique qui se veut efficace
donc on voit qu'on est en train d'être
un peu dans une autre histoire que celle
du départ du macronisme même si le
macronisme de départ voulait de
l'efficacité mais là on voit qu'on a
quelque chose qui s'est venu qui est
venu se greffer qui la question de
l'autorité et c'est V dans l'imaginaire
politique français la question de
l'autorité ça sonne plutôt côté droite
que côté gauche oui même si j'entends ce
que dit Bruno est tout à fait juste moi
je suis frappé à travers toutes nos
enquêtes de alors je le dis peut-être un
peu directement de l'effondrement ou de
l'atténuation très forte du clage droit
sur toute une série de sujets qui par le
passé séparé fortement dans les points
de vue les représentations et les
valeurs sympathisant de gauche et
sympathisant de droite sur Lim migration
on en a parlé ici quand on a une
majorité de sympathisants LR qui disent
oui pourquoi pas régulariser au cas par
cas des étrangers sans papi dans dans
des métiers en tension et à gauche
presque tr/4 de sympathisants de gauche
qui disent il faut expulser les
délinquants étrangers à l'issu de leur
peine on voit que les lignes ont très
fortement bougé et c'est vrai que
Gabriel Atal c'est début plutôt réussi
c'est avoir être parvenu dans une
logique de distinction par rapport à
Emmanuel Macron d'incarner une forme
d'autorité et d'avoir un imposer une
méthode la méthode en deux points dire
les choses faire les constats ne pas
être dans le dénis et essayer de les
solutionner essayer de faire beaucoup
d'annonces et c'est ça c'est moins sur
Gabriel Atal le fait qu'il soit associé
à des valeurs de droite qu'il est
maintenant alors je pas citer la méthode
rard des années 80 mais qu'il associé à
une méthode qu'on a bien vu déployer l
du discours de politique générale et ça
pose la question des LR et des relation
entre Gabriel hatal et et leslr Alex
est-ce que Gabriel hatal poursuit sa
stratégie d'affaiblissement et à l'air
mais oui alors même si le premier
ministre considère les républicains
comme une formation politique avec qui
il peut nouer sur certains textes des
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et bien
il poursuit effectivement une stratégie
d'affaiblissement de la droite qui avait
été initiée par Emmanuel Macron en 2017
avec plusieurs angles d'attaque d'abord
la vieille technique du débauchage des
figures de la droite les anciennes
ministres sarkozistes Rachid adatie et
Catherine Vautrin sont rentrés dans le
gouvernement Atal et ça a passablement
agacé les républicains écoutez Bruno
rotaillot le patron des sénateurs LR le
débauchage le débauchage ne fait ni de
bien à la démocratie ni de bien ni de
bien à la politique parce que signifiait
que tout se vaut la droite comme la
gauche la fidélité comme les revirements
ça veut dire que rien ne vaut et que
tout est faux et je m'honore qu'ici au
Sénat il y ait des femmes des hommes de
loyauté à gauche comme à droite qui
considéront toujours que l'ambition est
en en dessous de la conviction la
conviction au-dessus de
l'ambitiono qui s'adressait à Rachid
adati mais aussi peut-être au sénateurs
les républicains qui pourrai être tenté
d'accepter un poste ministériel dans la
suite de ce remanement autre autre angle
d'attaque du Premier ministre contre la
droite et bien s'approprier son discours
sa communication dans sa déclaration de
politique générale Gabriel Atal a
multiplié les références à l'autorité à
l'ordre Bruno en parlait avec la fameuse
formule tu casses tu répares tu salis tu
nettoies tu défies l'autorité on
t'apprend à la respecter des références
également à l'identité de notre pays à
la souveraineté de la France c'était des
marqueurs qu'on avait peu vu dans le
macronisme et qui font quand même partie
du logiciel des républicains que leslr
ne peuvent pas nier et puis autre coup
dur porté au LR l'épilogue de la loi
immigration le gouvernement a attendu
tranquillement que le Conseil
constitutionnel censure toutes les
mesures qui avaient été ajoutées par
leslr au texte des mesures mesure de
durcissement la loi a été censurée
partiellement et elle a tout de suite
été promulguée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur géralde dararmanin sur ordre
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis concernant la
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État
promise par ellisabeth borne OLR elle se
fera en contournant le Parlement par
voie réglementaire et avec seulement
quelques ajustements et pas une
restriction du panier de soins comme
souhaité par les républicains beaucoup
de cûts portés OLR ce qui rouvre
l'hypothèse d'une motion de censure qui
pourrait être déposé par les députés LR
dans un avenir proche le président du
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale
Olivier marlex l'a évoqué dans une
réunion de groupe la semaine dernière à
l'Assemblée et on a même senti une
petite menace dans sa réponse au
discours de Gabriel hatal la semaine
dernière
écoutez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous nous auriez demandé notre confiance
après ces 7 années de pouvoir nous
n'aurions évidemment pas pu vous la
donner mais nous ne vous empêcherons pas
d'agir tâchez de faire mieux que ce qui
vous a demandé par le président et
souvenez-vous que la durée de vie de
votre gouvernement ne dépend pas que du
président de la République mais aussi de
cette Assemblée nationale où vous êtes
minoritaire et dont vous n'aurez pas la
confiance voilà le message est passé en
tout cas s'il y avait une motion de
censure déposée par des députés LR elle
aurait euh plus de chance d'être voté et
par le RN et par la gauche et donc
d'être adopté mais bon pour l'instant ce
n'est qu'une arme de dissuasion est-ce
qu'elle est lisible la stratégie des
républicains dans l'opinion
clairement non elle n'est pas lisible
c'est le problème de l'espace politique
réduit dont pâtissent les républicain on
peut résumer le champ politique depuis
des années à une guerre des trois blocs
he le bloc nupes lui-même assez fracturé
le bloc de gauche le bloc central et le
bloc RN reconquête où se trouvent les
républicains on peut parler de victoire
idéologique Alexandre l'a bien dit sur
toute une série de sujets de valeurs qui
faisaent partie du du logiciel de droite
et qui ce sont je le disais 10 fusé hein
à l'ensemble des Français y compris des
français de gauche mais ce que dit Bruno
Rago est très fort sur les convictions
contre l'ambition contre les débauchages
mais un on ne peut pas empêcher ces
débauchages ils ont commencé dès 2017 et
il faut le dire chez les sympathisants
LR jamais édard Philippe quasiment
jamais gérérald Darmanin Bruno Lemer
n'ont étit vu comme des comme des
traîtres les Françaises sont de moins en
moins sur cette logique de
bipolarisation gauche-doite donc pour
les républicains le problème qui s'est
posé aux européennes en 2019 qui a coûté
cher avant saxavier benami en 2022 le
vote utile qui a dont a pti Valérie pcrè
avec sa campagne aussi compliquée à tous
les risques de se reproduire et on verra
l'annonce du nouveau gouvernement quit
d'une personnalité forte des
républicains qui rejoindrait le
gouvernement c'est plus que jamais un
problème d'espace avec euh ça se passe à
droite ça se passe nulle part ça se
passe partout si je puis dire il y a une
droite qui est dans la macronie il y a
une droite au rassemblement national
Marine Le Pen une code de popularité
dans le baromètre FO fucial pour match
qui dépasse je crois 40 ou 45 % et il
reste se réduit ce canal historique il
ne faut pas sous-estimer qui est très
fort à l'échelle locale mais qui peine à
exister nationalement est-ce que Gabriel
Atal a intérêt à débaucher de nouveau
Alair politiquement Bruno
oui sans doute parce que il y a touours
ce problème de majorité qu' n'a pas à
l'Assemblée mais on voit bien que même
sil déb chez DLR ça ne lui rapporterait
pas nécessairement des voix à
l'Assemblée pour faire valider les les
les textes euh donc après je dirais que
l'intérêt voilà c'est compliqué la la
question de l'autorité on voit qu'il
veut venir sur des thématiques qui ont
été effectivement très longtemps des
thématiques incarnées par la par la
droite mais mais mais mais du coup ça
génère et ça pose plein d'autres
questions deux questions la première le
volet efficacité euh le Premier ministre
communique beaucoup sur cette dimension
mais l'efficacité n'est pas un projet de
société ça n'est pas un projet politique
c'est un moyen l'efficacité et ça ne
règle toujours pas le problème de savoir
vers où on va dans les 2 3 ans qui Arve
quel est le projet politique deuxième
2uxème question la question de
l'autorité mais qui pourrait être contre
on voit que ça veut parler au au à la
profondeur du pays ou dans les familles
on va dire tu as vu le premier ministre
il a dit il faut bien travailler à
l'école il faut respecter le maître et
tu tu tu casses sur répart mais il y a
un peu de facilité il y a un petit peu
de facilité dans dans dans dans ça tout
le monde t tous les Françaises les
Français ils éduquent leur gamin avec
l'idée tu cas surépart bien bien
évidemment mais il y a une autre
question quand on pose la question de
l'autorité c'est la question des droit
de celui qui doit obéir à l'autorité et
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans des
sociétés compliquées où ça n'est plus
comme avant comme il y a 30 ans 40 ans
50 ans où on dit tu casses tu répares
mais là aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
vont dire oui mais pourquoi tu as cassé
qu'est-ce qui t'a amené à casser et donc
la question des droits qui
accompagne la question du retour de
l'autorité me semble être un point
aveugle qui ne permet pas de
complètement comprendre on va parler d'
dernier point sur la manière de
gouverner un Moot Alex juste c'est très
étonnant car Gabriel il pourrait
gouverner avec les républicains les les
programmes politiques vraiment
convergent pour avoir une majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
mais ces deux formations la majorité
présidentielle et LR reste concurrente
avec ceci système présidentiel français
et donc l'objectif c'est de grappiller
du terrain sur l'autre de s'envoyer des
coups des piic et il y a peut-être un
autre coup que j'avais pas cité un autre
piège tendu aur c'est l'introduction de
l'IVG du droit à l'avartement dans la
Constitution c'est une réforme souhaitée
par Emmanuel Macron et la majorité
présidentielle et gerérard Larché le
président du Sénat Breno rotayo ont
exprimé leur opposition à cette réforme
qu'il considèent inutile au risque
peut-être
de passer pour rétrograde en tout cas
c'est le piège qui est tendu par le
gouvernement la majorité présidentielle
OLR mais sur sur la manière de gouverner
parce qu'on a l'impression que Gabriel
hatal il veut un peu courtcircuiter le
Parlement gouverner plus par par décret
par règlement est-ce que du coup ça rend
les LR d'autant moins indispensable bah
oui alors c'est vrai qu'il veut faire ce
qu'il a fait à l'éducation nationale
c'est vraiment c'est 6 mois c'est cette
courte période et sa véritable matrice
et explique ce crédit de confiance qu'il
a auprès des Français c'est l'acte lourd
de sa vie politique en passant par
circulaire en courtcircuitant un petit
peu le Parlement il évite deux travers
qui ont coûté cher à sa prédécesseur
madame borne l'usage des 493 et si je
puux dire la bordélisation de
l'Assemblée nationale qu'on a vu pendant
la réforme des retraites qui a donné un
très mauvais une très mauvaise image du
Parlement donc dans ce auprès de
l'opinion c'est c'est plus ça rapporte
plus de court-circuiter le
Parlement
î
quiésentation pense que ça ça peut être
un atout pour lui ce que vient de dire
Alexandre sur l'inscription de l'IVG
dans du droit l'IVG dans la Constitution
ce n'est absolument pas un enjeu fait
d'opinion on l'a mesuré on l'a testé on
est sur 82 ou 95 % de Français favorabl
y compris chez SAP enant en jouant
peut-être le peuple de droite ou de
gauche contre les eu de droite ou de
gauche c'est une manière de les
consacuter maintenant il pourra quand
même pas se passer complètement du
Parlement et français ont plutôt
apprécié malgré ce que j'ai appelé de la
bandalisation les débats pendant les
l'année 2023 et il ne pourra pas
complètement faire fit de cela un
dernier mot Bruno il nous reste 30
secondes sur la manière de gouverner sur
le fait que le Parlement semble être un
peu court-circuité il y a un enjeu quand
même très très important on est une
grande démocratie on peut pas avoir
quand même les principaux texes et
notamment la loi de finances qui est
quand même le cœur de l'activité
parlementaire pendant 5 ans qui ne sera
adopté qu'au 493 sans débat
parlementaire on voit que ça pose quand
même une question importante donc il
reste effectivement pour le Premier
ministre un très gros enjeu arriver à
montrer qu'il peut gouverner pas
seulement à coup de décret mais
effectivement faant travailler le
Parlement avec lui allez on regarde
avant de se quitter ce qu'elle a une de
nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Alex on continue de parler
de ce remanimement qui n'en finit pas
c'est à la Une de La Dépêche oui cela
fait 3 semaines que Gabriel hatal a
nommé ses principaux ministre et la
suite du remaniement se fait attendre
avec plusieurs questions qui se posent
d'abord le sort de la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale et des Sports
améie ouéa Castera qui a connu des
débuts très compliqués dans ce ministère
de l'Éducation avec beaucoup de polémiqu
et puis une autre question y aura-t-il
de nouveau débauchage à droite après
l'arrivée de Rachida Dati et puis
François Baayou fera-t-il son entrée au
gouvernement le patron du MoDem qui a
été relaxé dans l'affaire des emplois
fictifs d'assistants parlementaires de
son mouvement faute de preuve et hier
soir il il n'écartait pas un retour au
gouvernement tout en évoquant je cite le
Très Grand T de très grands troubles au
sein de l'éducation nationale donc
l'ambition du maire de peau est à peine
voilé il y a de la friture sur la ligne
entre les nationalistes cors et l'État
c'est la ligne de Corse Matin oui Corse
Matin s'interroge sur l'annulation de la
visite cette semaine du ministre du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald de
Darmanin en Corse alors première raison
la propriété d'éc duporetti le ministre
de la Justice en Corse a été visité ce
weekend par des membres du groupe
indépendantiste Coré in fronté et les
élus nationalistes ont tardé à condamner
cet acte ce que ce qui explique
officiellement le report de cette visite
ministérielle mais la vraie cause selon
cors matin c'est que les élus cors ne
sont pas d'accord entre eux sur le
processus d'autonomie de l'île de beauté
qui doit être négocié avec Paris 17000
emplois à pourvoir dans la vallée des
batteries électriques c'est dans le nord
de la France et oui c'est à la une de la
voie du Nord c'est giga Factory de
batteries électriques destinées à
l'automobile auront besoin d'ici à 2027
d'une diversité de métiers technicien de
maintenance ingénieur conducteur de
ligne 30 métiers clés ont été identifiés
des métiers plutôt bien rémunérés
d'ailleurs un technicien de maintenance
dans ces gigafactory gagnera entre 40000
et 50000 € brut annuel donc avis au
candidat on finit par la Une de
Sud-Ouest Alex sur l'infertilité et les
défis de la science mais oui
souvenez-vous Emmanuel Macron a annoncé
sa volonté de relancer la natalité du
pays et il a prévu un grand plan de
lutte contre l'infertilité en France on
le rappelle un couple sur sur 4 est
touché par ses problèmes d'infertilité
et le journal Sud-Ouest propose un
reportage au service de reproduction de
l'hôpital de Bordeaux he qu'on appelé
autrefois banque de sperme et ce service
il est débordé par la demande de femmes
pour conserver leurs ovocite en 2023 ce
centre a à conservver les oites de 200
femmes mais selon ses responsables il
aurait dû en faire pour 800 femmes je
cite l'un de ses responsables nous
sommes obligés de refuser les demandes
de 10 femmes chaque semaine donc l'offre
en la matière doit encore progresser
merci Alex pour cette revue de presse
merci Frédéric David merci Bruno cotz
d'avoir été avec nous merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous à
18h sens public ce soir vous retrouvez
Mathieu croissand d'au et nous on se
retrouve demain très bonne
journée